PLEASE TELL ME
THERE'S SOMETHING NEXT.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
I GOT A BETTER IDEA.
LET'S MAKE THIS
MORE INTERESTING.
[slapping]
OKAY.
- MORE INTERESTING?
- YEAH, INTERESTING.
- OKAY, I, FOR ONE,
AM INTRIGUED.
NOW LET'S SEE
HOW A SHIRTLESS BLACK MAN
WITH A BOTTLE FULL OF BABY OIL
MAKES THINGS MORE INTERESTING
IN THIS WEEK'S BREAKDOWN.
[applause]
- LET'S MAKE THIS
MORE INTERESTING.
- IS THE SUSPENSE KILLING YOU?
BOOM.
WELCOME TO BLACK GUY HEAVEN!
THE BLUR IS
FOR YOUR OWN PROTECTION, PEOPLE.
I HAVE YET TO SPOT
ONE ACTUAL VAGINA,
AND I'VE BEEN WATCHING
THIS VIDEO FOR A WEEK.
NIGHT SCHOOL SPRING BREAK
RULES!
THAT DUDE IS SHOWING
AMAZING RESTRAINT.
WHY DON'T YOU JUMP IN A FOLD?
GUN TO MY HEAD,
I'M GOING WITH THE CHICK
WITH PINK HAIR.
SHE HAS KIND OF
A KATE UPTON THING GOING ON.
THAT IS WHY YOU NEVER BUY
A USED TWISTER
AT PLAY IT AGAIN SPORTS.
IT'S MORE LIKE
HUNGRY HUNGRY HIPPOS.
THEY WORK WELL TOGETHER.
CAN THEY PASS BLOCK?
LET'S SEND 'EM DOWN TO MIAMI.
KEEP TANNEHILL ON HIS FEET
THIS SEASON.
LEFT HOOF GREEN.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO LOSE
AT TWISTER
WHEN YOU'RE TOUCHING
EVERY DOT AT ALL TIMES.
ALL RIGHT, WHICH ONE OF YOU
JABBA THE SLUTS ATE THE SPINNER?
NOT COOL.
IS THAT A BITE MARK?
UGH.
ONE OF THEM MUST HAVE THOUGHT
HER NIPPLE
WAS A PIECE OF SALAMI.
[audience groaning]
ALL RIGHT, CALM DOWN.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN
TWO BEANBAG CHAIRS
TONGUE-KISS BEFORE?
LOOKS LIKE HE'S DETAILING
A WINNEBAGO BACK THERE.
BLACKFISH 2
IS WAY LESS DEPRESSING...
[chuckles]
MAYBE MORE.
JUST MAKE SURE YOU SAVE
SOME BABY OIL TO HELP THEM
SQUEEZE THROUGH THE DOOR
WHEN IT'S TIME TO LEAVE.
AND FOR THAT, WE THANK YOU.